what's going on there reject nation we
are back at it to check out another
video from new rock stars talking about
some multiverse of madness and now we
got to discuss whether or not superior
iron man will be in this movie or not i
just want to say if superior iron man is
in here they better make him full-on
villain because that guy is messed up
and if they can get tom cruise to play
the god complex narcissistic maniacal
iron man that would be amazing guys
leave a like if you're here subscribe to
new rockstars let's get to it
[Music]
welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness's latest trailer
just delivered some of the biggest
marvel fan payoff ever by confirming
patrick stewart charles xavier leader of
the x-men as part of the mcu now but
there is an even crazier cameo in this
trailer if you listen closely to the
illuminati shaming doctor strange in
that moment we should tell him the truth
i don't ever want to see it again
yes between a mystery glowing you gotta
basically breeding
the gold standard
as the foot soldiers of this illuminati
citadel speculation has exploded that a
variant of tony stark the superior iron
man could appear in multiverse of
madness maybe even played by long-time
band casted tom cruise who alongside
robert downey jr back in the mid-2000s
was originally considered for the role
of iron man giving us a glimpse into
that alternate reality but i'm gonna
explain who exactly this alternate
version of tony stark is the multiversal
logic that makes his membership on the
illuminati perfect for the mcu and what
role he could play in multiverse of
madness and beyonce
trailer doctor strange is detained in a
facility that's actually shot in
london's british museum home of the
rosetta stone an artifact really used as
the next point among anthropologists to
help them bridge together various
ancient languages which may be why
charles xavier as a student of history
chose this whole book as his nexus
bridge across realities but doctor
strange is escorted by ultron sentries
these are the drones built by ultron in
age of ultron but originally part of
tony stark's iron legion protocol to
build a suit of armor around the world
until the mine stone ai corrupted the
algorithm and turned it to evil but the
fact that these are now the foot
soldiers tell us that someone in this
compound is using this exact generation
of stark tech but as stark initially
intended it to work then strange face is
a six-chaired deus helmed by patrick
stewart charles xavier with the other
five authorities for now at least left a
mystery but this is almost certainly
marvel's six-member illuminati which in
the comics was founded by tony stark now
throughout this trailer wanda breaks
into an attacks this compound facing at
least one glowing figure now in most of
these shots the person looks like monica
rambo or her mother maria rambo going
binary the way captain marvel does but
maybe monica tapping into her photon
abilities that she gained in wandavision
now i will admit some angles look a bit
more armored up and if you pause at one
particular frame the motion blur does
make the figure look like the hair is
different and the lighting around the
mouth a bit more goatee like it's just
hard to tell with this quality one still
frame being shared around twitter from
bfx still being rendered doesn't really
do it justice ultimately i just doubt
marvel would introduce a variant tony
stark like
this is so strategic and so deliberate
with how they teased patrick stewart but
i totally get why fans think iron man
will show up in this movie and i totally
agree with him well based off of that
image that was circulating what was
funny is that they showed that a moment
from there in both the tv spot and the
actual trailer and they both look
slightly different when you look at the
one for the official trigger like okay
that looks definitely more masculine it
looks more male that could be superior
iron man especially when you throw feel
to the fire of the fact that the creator
of superior iron man was on twitter and
saying we don't have any inside
information but when he does get mad he
does turn red and orange so that was
like a baby but him but that at the same
time on these other frames it looks way
more like it's rambo so maybe it's a
different animation in each trailer
because marvel does love to do that too
mess with the vfx to throw us off based
on the ultron sentries alone and this
being a multiversal illuminati this has
to be pointing at superior iron man and
multiverse madness in the marvel comics
superior iron man emerged from what was
called the axis event in which magic
reversed the morality of earth's heroes
and villains but the corrupted tony
stark shielded himself from that spell
being reversed and so he stayed evil
becoming what was known as the superior
iron man he got society addicted to the
extremist 3.0 virus via an addiction
he used an army of drones as a police
force until the jackass was eventually
killed off in an incursion when the
marvel universe in the ultimate universe
collided which was part of the stepping
stones leading up to the 2015 secret
wars event all of this lines up
perfectly with what marvel studios now
seems to be setting up with an ultron
century guarded multiverse overseeing
illuminati as this entire cinematic
universe braces for future crossover
events like avengers secret wars okay
you see like just talk about that or
you're going to dive into the role a
little bit more but i was i was talking
with koidra who actually was saying that
he thinks that everyone in the
illuminati perhaps might be like an
alternate evil version of themselves
because i was like okay let's say it is
superior iron man why would superior
iron man be part of the illuminati who
wants to do like good things right
potentially that's the intent the guys
of good things yeah but superior iron
man he's messed up man and he only looks
out for himself works under the guise of
helping people but he takes glee and
like sometimes watching people suffer as
long as he can have gains so i'm like
maybe he's actually like one of the
secret villains for this movie more than
just a cameo but you know we'll see what
else uh eric has to say by simply
including these ultron sentries this
confirms this compound runs on star tech
but coming from a universe where ultron
drones can be trusted and controlled
while one could argue that they're being
controlled
ultron himself i just don't think ultron
or ultron infinity would really want to
join any multiversal council rather this
looks like a successfully realized
version of tony stark's original
intention for ultron to be a fully
automated ai designed to operate his
iron legion and keep the peace peace in
our time however let's game that out if
there were a reality in which ultron
never betrayed tony stark tony never
would have learned those critical
lessons or responsibility that age of
ultron taught him he never would have
moved avengers tower out of manhattan to
the more remote compound in upstate new
york there would have been no sokovia
disaster to guilt-trip him with in civil
war he just really would have spent a
lot more time drinking showing off
trying to lift mjolnir and making poorly
aged primonocta jokes yeah thanks for
that one joss to be honest he just would
have aged into a smug prick and hanging
out with killmongerine to a fleet of
drones and someone who super importantly
for this film never ever got to know the
sokovian twins whose parents were killed
would have been just some random hydra
controlled witch who gave him a
terrifying nightmare and then bounced
and we know how important that nightmare
was to the tony stark of the mcu but in
this case it leaves us with a
live-action version of the superior iron
man a jerk who loves to have his toys do
everything for him but a guy always
fearing the one witch who got away now
one in this trailer said that bitchin
theorized about the multiverse proving
that tony stark's jarvis ai tech
eventually would have explored
multiverse theory on its own and perhaps
given this tony stark variant access to
navigate the multiverse without having
to use linear quantum time travel like
our robert downey jr tony stark did now
again i think the basic a multiversal
illuminati tells us that this multiverse
is really worried about incursions and
it's all leading to what i believe will
be the fifth avengers film secret wars
and in the 2015 comics of that doctor
doom brings back all the marvel heroes
and villains in a big multiversal arena
called battle world it's awesome however
i would be surprised if superior iron
man even made it that far because if he
is played by a cameo as nuts as tom
cruise this sounds like a bit of stunt
casting in which tom cruise plays an
intel absolutely stealing roll where he
goes hard like he did for his cameo and
tropic thunder for cruz this would just
be the meta opportunity to show what he
could have done after he was considered
for the role in the mid-2000s before
robert downey jr was cast and just
really have fun with it lots of fun
until the ghost of his past bloody wanda
kicks down the door and wipes the floor
with him i would just hope that before
that happens this movie could show us a
quick what if style montage of this iron
man's past history but those iconic mcu
moments tom cruise swapped in for robert
downey jr like hammering the armor in
the cave with a box of scraps pulling
off his shades during the press
conference saying
iron man teaming up with war machine and
iron man 2 except now it's back to being
terrence howard yeah all the way to his
fateful line to thanos and end game i
mean i don't think we would do terror
tower i think i think they're trying to
make us completely forget about two
because that would that that would mean
after iron man then we entered the
multiverse right then and there i think
i'm going to maintain the wall between
the mcu and terence howard because
that's not part of the fun
real life conflict even in what if they
always make it don cheadle when they go
back to the events of iron man 1
and there's a reason they don't even
acknowledge ever norton hell disney and
lucasfilm already hired vfx artist
shamook to fix luke skywalker and this
guy made a great rendering of tom cruise
as iron man i mean who knows that much
oh man that's why this guy was hired so
i just cannot wait to see this superior
iron man freak out when wanda begins
yanking out the hearts of his precious
ultrons
check out our great
com follow me on instagram and twitter
at ee avast paula new rockstar
subscribed into rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
that that yell from the mummy trailer is
uh more iconic than anything from the
actual movie itself all right guys well
i think that's a great justification for
superior iron man to be here i would
want him to be more than just a cameo
but a little bit of a supporting role
that's just my one wish that if you're
gonna get tom cruise to step in here
wanted more than just a wink because
we're gonna get a lot of winks of the
audience with these cameos i imagine oh
for sure let's make some of them actual
substance yeah all right guys thanks for
being here what do you think about tom
cruise possibly showing up in this movie
see you guys soon subscribe to new
rockstars
[Music]